-Welcome to "Late Night."
We are gonna move on after this,
I promise,
and try our very best
to have a normal show,
but something happened
this weekend,
and we're gonna do our best
to address it now,
while appreciating
that we might not be
the best people
to talk about it.
But on Saturday,
a gunman entered a supermarket
in a Black neighborhood
in Buffalo
with an assault weapon
and shot 13 people,
killing 10 of them.
It's an absolute nightmare.
And worse, it's a story
we've now seen
dozens and dozens of times.
And this time,
there was a small detail
in the reporting
from The New York Times
that caught my eye --
just this one sentence.
"A gun dealer who said
he sold the suspect
an assault weapon
in recent months
described
a routine transaction."
We live in a country --
and I don't know
when it happened --
where an 18-year-old boy
goes into a gun dealership
to buy an assault weapon,
and it's a routine transaction.
Under the same legal system
that won't let a person
buy a six-pack of Bud Light
because it would be dangerous.
But an assault rifle,
that's routine now.
The implications is
that 18-year-old boys
go into that gun dealer and
buy weapons of war regularly.
When a cable-news host
opens his show
with a red-faced rant about
white people being replaced,
that's considered a typical
episode of that show.
Routine and typical.
Words like
"shocking" and "stunning"
are slowly draining out of
the conversation
about mass shootings,
and words like "routine"
and "typical"
are taking their place.
I don't know what this means,
but it feels like bad news
on top of all the bad news.
The usual voices are on TV today
blaming the dark corners
of the Internet,
video games, and
offering thoughts and prayers.
And that, for sure,
is routine and typical.
People are saying,
"We should concern ourself
with mental-health issues,
rather than
gun control or motive."
And maybe that's true
in some cases,
but in this case, the
motive was crystal clear.
This shooter is
a white supremacist.
And I'm sad
that hearing that phrase,
"The shooter is
a white supremacist,"
has also become routine.
Incredibly sad.
Now, those are just my thoughts
on these events,
but this news
hit everyone differently.
So, here with her own response
is one of our own writers,
Amber Ruffin.
[ Applause ]
-Hey. Hey, everyone.
Seth is right.
The news is awful.
I feel like [Bleep].
I feel unsafe.
This is an extremely bad day.
But a bad day for me might
just be a good day for you.
-How so, Amber?
-Let me show you.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪ Yes it's a good day for you,
not for me ♪
♪ And it's a good day
for sailin' at sea ♪
♪ Yes, it's a good day
'cause none of us are free ♪
♪ Till it's a good day for you
to denounce white supremacy ♪
-I'm sorry. What?
-I don't know, man.
I tried everything else.
Maybe a little song will do it?
-Oh, Amber, you think a song
will change all this?
-Dude, if this had been
the original words
to this old-ass song,
we may not be in this mess.
-Amber!
-Oh, my bad.
Let's try 400 more
"Closer Looks."
-Alright. Fair. Continue.
-Thank you.
[ Up-tempo music continues ]
♪ And it's a good day
for taking a nap ♪
to dust off your cap ♪
♪ So pay attention
and avoid all the traps ♪
♪ Yes, it's a good day ♪
♪ To tell
your old racist relatives ♪
♪ You're not having
their crap ♪
-Amber?
-Someone has to try
to get through to them.
I mean, have your attempts
been successful?
-Please continue.
♪♪
-♪ I said to the sun,
good morning, sun ♪
♪ It's time to illuminate ♪
♪ And he said to me,
"Well, there's got to be ♪
♪ A way that we can get rid of
all of this hate ♪
♪ 'Cause it's a good day
to get a checkup ♪
♪ And it's a good day
to fill up your cup ♪
♪ So take a deep breath,
give your life a cleanup ♪
♪ 'Cause it's a good day
to realize ♪
♪ That these white supremacists
feel safe ♪
♪ In this society we created ♪
♪ So it's the society
that has to change ♪
♪ And make these people
uncomfortable ♪
♪ And a good way
to start that is ♪
♪ When you hear them
say a racist thing ♪
♪ To tell them to ♪
♪ Shut ♪
♪ The ♪
♪ [Bleep] ♪
♪ U-U-Up ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!
Thank you, Amber.